[موسيقى]
لغه من الارق المهيب حروفها تهت المواسم
في الصبح
لغه الجمال كانما نفحاتها
للعاشقين من السماء هديه تمتد بين
الناطقين بها كما رحم وفي رحم اللغات
لغتي اي لغه
المفاخر كلما ناديتها وقف الزمان تحيه اجد
بها عزا
فيرتشف المدى نغما سماويا
عشقت رايه هذه الابيات من قصيره
للشاعر عيسى
اسمي جاسمين وعمري ثمانيه سنوات احب
السباحه
والكتابه
واعشق اللغه العربيه
بدات قصصي مع العربيه عندما كانت امي
تاسيلي كل يوم قصه وتحكيها لي وكنت الاحظ
ان طريقتها مختلفه عما نتحدث وسالت امي
لماذا
اجابتني امي هذه هي اللغه العربيه الصحيحه
وهي لغهنا في الاساس نحن العرب منذ زمن
طويل
واما ما نتحدث به فيسمى اللهجه العاميه
والان اصبحت لكل دوله عربيه لهجتها الخاصه
بها
واخبرتني ايضا ان اللغه العربيه من اقدم
اللغات وهي اللغه التي اختارها الله
وحدثنا بها في القران ومن هنا بدات قصتي
مع العربيه طلبت من امي ان اتعلم اللغه
العربيه
واحضرت لامي قصه قصصا باللغه العربيه
واصبحت تحكيها لي كل يوم حتى كبرت واصبحت
انا التي اقرب نفسي اه نسيت ان اخبركم اني
احب القراءه كثيرا فقد تعلمت منها الكثير
والكثير وايضا كنت ادرس قصصا من ادب الطفل
وبعدها لمعت في عقلي فكره شعرت بشغفي وحبي
يا نؤلف بنفسي قصصا باللغه العربيه لاني
اريدكم يا اصدقائي ان تستفيدوا مثل ما
استفاد وتستمتعوا مثل ما استمتعت وتحبون
القراءه مثل ما احببتها
وكانت هذه اول مره لي ولكني فشلت الامر
ليس بالسهل ولكني لمياس وحاولت مره اخرى
فبحثت على الانترنت عن كيفيه كتابه قصص
وصياغتها
وايضا كنت ادرس المعجم وكنت ادرس الكثير
من المفردات التي ساعدتني في التعبير عن
مشاعري وعن افكاري
فاللغه العربيه غنيه وثريه بالمفردات التي
نستطيع ان اعبر بها عن مشاعرنا
عن افكارنا
وكنت ادرس في دار لتعلم العربيه وكان يدرس
معي اصدقائي من دول اخرى مثل
الجزائر والمغرب ومنهم من دول الغربيه
وانا من مصر
كل واحد منهم يتحدثوا بالهجته العاميه
فاذا تحدث كل واحد بلهجته لن يفهم احد
صديقه ولكن عندما تجمعنا العربيه نرى
نفسنا اننا نستمتع بالحديث اكثر
وبعد كل هذا رجعت للقصص ووجدت نفسي اني
افضل بكثير
لان تعلمي اللغه العربيه
افادني في كثير من الاشياء
فتذكروا اسمي جيدا ولا تنسوا فربما تجدوه
في احدى القصص
في خانه المؤلف
فانا اريدك يا اصدقائي ان تتعلموا اللغه
العربيه وان تفخروا بلغتكم
واخيرا اريد ان اشكر معلمي معلمي اللغه
العربيه الذي ساعدني في تذوق اللغه
العربيه
[تصفيق]